guess that valley of fire state park are
hiking through history this red
sandstone that makes the park famous was
formed millions of years ago before the
popular hiking trails and campgrounds
the valley of fire was a way of travel
in the early 1900's a road was forged
through the area to connect Salt Lake
City and Los Angeles a person coined the
name while traveling through the park at
sunset saying the entire valley looked
like it was on fire the colors change
they go from such a bright white to a
deep red and the sand is like deep and
dark red like I've never seen that on
any beach it's good to be out here you
know in the fresh air against some Sun
vitamin D in the 1920s eighty-five
hundred acres of the land was given to
Nevada the park has now grown to more
than forty thousand acres it's always
interesting to see that the diversity of
the rocks and everything there is to see
there's the whole valley of fire and
it's it's definitely you know unique
sites here that you don't see anywhere
else
outdoor enthusiasts flocked to the
various hiking trails and campsites some
saying it feels like they're in another
world in another oasis not far from the
Las Vegas Strip there's so much to see
out here between the hiking and off-road
trails that I want to come out and do
some of the off-road trails next time
I just love there's so many different
looks in every different direction from
Vegas you can just go from beautiful
Lakes to Mount Charleston Valley fire to
everywhere Keith Houston reporting from
the valley of fire state park in
Southern Nevada